der eigentliche erfolg von olaf scholz
war doch gar nicht gestern im trial die
leistung nein wir eigentlich erfolg von
olaf scholz ist wie er seine leute im
griff hat ich meine dass das kästen die
einladung zu einer will aus schlug das
ist der große erfolg von urlaubs und das
ist das wofür man ihn loben sollte das
erschafft enteignungs kevin versteckt
mich sagt ja und den corona haben in
lauterbach einfach zu verstecken und
damit auch die linken fantasien
das ist mal eine ansage mir naja du
traust dich also ich fast noch mal ganz
kurz zusammen nämlich spannende
geschichte gestern bei der kollegin anne
will eigentlich eingeladen war saskia
esken die tauchte dann aber nicht auf
stattdessen malu dreyer und anne will
sagte ja nein das hatte terminliche
gründe daraufhin der kollege robin
alexander unser geschätzter kollege von
der welt nicht das hat er keine
terminlichen gründen ich habe jedoch
eben noch gegenüber einer pommesbude
gesehen hätte problemlos herkommen sieht
also tatsächlich bisschen so aus als
würden jetzt würde die spd einige leute
im wahlkampf derzeit eher verstecken ja
wenn man wahlbürger ist und ich bin
einer also wenn man nicht politisch
besonders informiert ist dann schwankt
man ja zwischen den figuren hin und her
man braucht ja in den tief ika zions
figuren wo man sagen kann ich will den
an der macht sehen in anführungszeichen
deswegen wenig den also ich sags ja es
kommt zum ersten mal gesagt ich gedacht
also spd kannst du nicht weh als ich
wiege winter zum ersten mal gesehen habe
heute das war von heinrich gehört wenn
die cdu solche jungen kräfte hat ist das
für mich auch ein grund also ich weiß
nicht was ich treibe ehrlich gesagt in
der wahlkabine aber es ist so wichtig
dass wir figuren sehen vor an denen wir
uns quasi auch entweder reiben können
oder mit denen wir uns identifizieren
und kevin und saskia ist kein traumpaar
für mich wo ich sage das sind meine
leute den lege ich mein schicksal als
bürger in die hände und das macht nicht
richtig sein das mag auch nicht
abgeklärt sein dieses urteil aber so
sind wir und ich glaube viele viele
millionen in deutschland denkt auch so
thematisch nicht die wenig schnell ich
habe ja auch das gefühl dass das
durchaus bewusst ist dieses verstecken
von manchen figuren die vielleicht nicht
wirklich
sehr geschmeidigen sehr bürgerlichen
auftritt von olaf scholz passen wird
kevin kühnert inzwischen macht sich
dadurch aber auch in muss man sagen
teilweise sehr unterhaltsames spiel auf
twitter und schreibt immer heute
verstecke ich mich in folgender torture
macht also deutlich er wird eigentlich
gar nicht verstecken glaubst du du hast
eben von durchgesprochen versucht das
team von olaf scholz wirklich ein paar
leute möglichst aus der öffentlichkeit
herauszuhalten die menschen vielleicht
angst machen könnten mit ihren
linksaußen zum beispiel enteignungs
fantasien ja das glaube ich schon denn
aber es gibt ja nicht so dass man sagt
ihr bleibt mir draußen mal ihr eure
fantasien passen jetzt nicht gerade
meinem einer wahlkampfstrategie bei hier
hat man sich dafür entschieden olaf
scholz in den mittelpunkt zu stellen
auch natürlich und alle anderen kein
team umzubauen anders als bei armin
laschet bei anderen lena berger kennt
man ja eigentlich auch nur sehen nicht
nur robert habeck damit der anton
hofreiter versteckt aber
hinter seiner eigenen frisur und
dann das ist sicherlich ein eins davon
zu sagen kevin kühnert hat die entra die
kali sierung von kenne kevin kühnert hat
angefangen als der stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender wurde und ich glaube
mittlerweile sieht er das selber als
fehler an weil dann nicht mehr so
auftreten kann wir auftreten getreten
ist er war in einigen talkshows darauf
hingewiesen hat sich da auch gebettelt
zehn jahre in einer also es ist schon
öffentlich zu sehen und sich nur seine
thesen sind nicht mehr stahl will nicht
mehr bmw festmahl handlichen zumindest
sagt das nicht mehr öffentlich saskia
esken würde sicherlich in einer solchen
talkshow nochmal gefragt werden wie
halten sie es denn mit rot-rot-grün sie
würde sagen da das finde ich gar nicht
so schlimm oder ja das muss eine option
bleiben ich denke das will man jetzt
nicht hören weil ich nachvollziehbar ist
man sagt jetzt bitte sie waren die
fritten wurde ist
zum schluss wieder die trojaner spd die
wir momentan haben man wollte olaf
scholz nicht als parteivorsitzenden
haben sondern hat saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans gewählt schickt
jetzt stolz aber trotzdem nach vorne
weil man weiß der sieht irgendwie gut
aus der kann auch sogar schon die merkel
raute machen dh die menschen finden das
vielleicht cool und versucht dann zu
verheimlichen mensch wir haben aber
eigentlich ein ganz anderen kurs denn
wenn wir mal auf die inhalte gucken und
nicht nur auf die personen die vorne
stehen dann habe ich selten so eine
linke spd erlebt wie in diesem wahlkampf
wenn ich mir die thesen angucke wenn ich
mir angucke was die sonst im programm
haben dass das dem stichpunkt europas
schulden union habe ich hier gerade
schon angesprochen habe auch sonst die
steuerpläne der spd sind ja zum teil
abendliche müsse aber ich bin ja nicht
der schulz verteidiger auch nicht dass
ich sage wenn ich sage dass er mann der
mitte ist oder dass auch sein will das
hat nichts damit zu tun aber es gibt
gewinnt natürlich weiß sie kennt ja auch
um fragen die person vorne zieht nicht
deswegen versucht wird natürlich man
jetzt hier auf inhalte zu gehen und
diese strecke bereits in dieser woche es
geht doch darüber
müsste man kann man sagen da ist es
jedoch seltsam dass sich da jemand
durchgesetzt hat in irgendwelchen
komischen präsidiumssitzung oder
anderswo wo eigentlich ein anderer
kandidat da stand der vielleicht den
veränderungswillen dieses landes dem
viel mehr entsprochen hätte und
eigentlich auch der kanzler der herzen
gewesen wäre und schwarz-grün sicherlich
in einem federstrich gemacht hätte
nämlich markus sowie interessante
parallele oder immerhin auf dem
parteitag gewählt während olaf scholz
jetzt glaube ich auch nicht
basisdemokratie interessante parallele
ist ja dass beide kandidaten von der
eigenen partei eigentlich nicht gewollt
war in einem fall scheint es gerade
schief zu gehen und im anderen scheint
es gerade gut zu gehen so zumindest die
umfrage moment was ich mich frage weil
es hier natürlich erkennbar ist dass
olaf scholz politisch ganz anderer typ
ist als esken kühnert novato wie und es
heißt ja immer wenn ihr jetzt in scholz
wählt dann macht ihr mit der ganzen
linken gerade dahinter auf gibt es eben
auch betont bilder kannte aber
beantworten wie mächtig ist so ein
bundeskanzler dann kann so ein
bundeskanzler dann sagen wenn er erst
mal bundeskanzler ist ihr habt mir alle
gar nichts mehr zu sagen ich bin der
kanzler ich habe die
richtlinienkompetenz ohne mich läuft
hier gar nichts ohne mich hätte er
keiner von euch die wahl gewonnen was
ihr sagt interessiert mich in der tat
ich habe euch im wahlkampf weggesperrt
hier ist bleibt dir bitte auch in
rhede
das interessiert mich auch ja so eintrag
geht es nicht aber ist olaf scholz ist
ein sehr guter verhandler und er wird
natürlich dann in der lage sein mit
dieser errungenen macht viel mehr von
dem durchzusetzen was eigentlich
durchsetzen will je nachdem welche
koalition er dann eingehen will aber
diesen kurs der mitte und er muss
natürlich kompromisse machen er muss
jemand aus diesem linken bereich nehmen
vielleicht wird der kühnheit euro
staatssekretär oder so hat gesagt saskia
esken ist ministrabel ich glaube nicht
dass ein minister werden wird aber muss
es natürlich machen man muss offen sein
am ende hat jemand der sich so
durchsetzt wenn er sich dann durchsetzen
kann das gehört dazu sehr viel macht und
kann natürlich auch entsprechende
duftmarken setzen sich dann frei
schwimmen muss aber sehen dass ihm
gerhard schröders 2005 passiert die
parteien nicht erfolgt und das ist ein
fortwährendes spiel ich heute weiß ich
jetzt noch mal ein etwas sagen ich meine
die geschichte der sozialdemokraten ist
natürlich zu sagen ja mensch armin
laschet üblich so richtig deswegen muss
er sich jetzt einem auch machen das ist
schlicht gesagt zu haben das ist ja
umfragen das ist eine geschichte die
jetzt gespannt wird aber zum schluss ist
ja das was die union macht zu zeigen
menschen die sind transparent dass
unsere leute das ist und jeder musiker
das ist ein beliebter das ist ein
beliebter unions finden muss ich aber
jetzt auch einmal ein bisserl ein
schreibt weil aus vielen gesprächen
wissen wir armin laschet wollte vieles
außer dem team und als es dann wirklich
katastrophal außer in den umfang konnte
man ihn dazu drängen dass er doch noch
ein team aufstellt und da hat er dann
auch noch einige leute also viele leute
aufgestellt jetzt eher der von der
mittlere probleme mein eindruck war
anders julia aber ist ja in ordnung aber
wenn das das team ist das reich mit
mussten dagegen sparen in dem teambus
frau kramp karrenbauer in dem team wo es
peter altmaier in dem team wo sind die
vielen anderen ministerinnen und
minister
den weg gab ich auch so frage das würde
nämlich heute freut auch heute abend ist
weil ich habe mich gefragt warum hat die
jungen und nun eigentlich selbst land
geschadet genauso wie söder das waren
zwei starke kräfte deswegen auch manch
einer meinem umfeld sagt naja die eigene
partei glaubt nicht an ihnen warum soll
ich ihn wählen also ihr wollt ihr
eigentlich die junge union du bist wie
so weit er gegen laschet und für söder
damit hat ihnen doch auch geschwächt na
ja wir haben eine demokratische
entscheidung gehabt im bundesvorstand
und da hatten die unterschiedlichen
gruppierungen unterschiedliche meinungen
und junge union hat sich mehrheitlich
für sogar ausgesprochen das gehört zu
einem demokratischen prozess dazu das
wäre ja schlimm wenn wir immer einer
meinung sein muss stimmt das haben wir
aus diskutiert öffentlicher als es mir
persönlich lieb gewesen wäre aber gut so
ist es halt aber da sieht man auch mal
demokratie lebt aber wichtig ist dass
man sich zum schluss geschlossen hinter
einen kandidaten stellt und wir haben
gerade eine mitmach tour gemacht da sind
drei busse durch ganz deutschland
getourt für armin laschet es gibt die
die home sweet germany die jetzt
aufgebaut wird von jordan besonders 1 0
fabian beine der sich da besonders
aufreißt um jetzt für armin laschet zu
kämpfen und das ist irgendwie das board
den wir als union da auch gemeinsam
harmloser geist bei der jungen union ob
das wirklich totale geschlossenheit ist
bei der union das wage ich noch ein
bisserl zu bezweifeln
[Musik]